ryan babel nadal qui viennent me dire un
truc tu trouveras vinyle agnel j'adore
cette émission je me sentais au fait
j'ai envie de me rapprocher de quelqu'un
et part sur la droite
voila voila c'est peut-être pas fuir
quand même cépage et je penche voyez
d'accord c'est vraiment hormonal alors
le look
non non non j'ai été et puis avec des
shorts des dommages au débat justement
on a une vidéo non look de daniel moreau
regarde c'est parti non vous avez un nom
une forme non j'ai changé en fait j'ai
changer de garde-robe
[Musique]
alors bon non mais c'est ça qui mourra à
vous j'avais une première ps que vous
voulez pas qu'à la rentrée on rouvre
look complètement grave on a essayé mais
là moi je vais essayer mais je vais
essayer en vrai vous allez voir on va
faire avait dit génial
donc je vais faire ma déclaration met à
genoux mais comme bon je suis un petit
peu âge et mes genoux craque donc pour
faire craquer j'ai pris moi j'ai acheté
regardez j'ai même oublié d'être lent
d'enlever les tilleuls j'ai acheté cet
après midi je vais me mettre à jour mais
bon tout comme ben oui pour fermer
rigueur exemplaire de vos envies
[Applaudissements]
romantique donc jean-michel voilà je
sens qu'on a on qu'on a du feeling même
si vous ne sentez pas encore je suis
toujours un petit peu en avance donc je
compte sur vous pour me lever au propre
comme au figuré
je suis pas sûr que je vais pouvoir me
relever là j'espère vous faire craquer
au moins autant que mes genoux crack en
ce moment valable
daniel vous avez 50 3 ans et vous n'avez
jamais été mariés non vous avez connu
combien de mecs dans votre vie 3 3 mecs
à quel âge j'ai commencé alors ça
commençait bien j'ai commencé jeune a 18
ans pile n'ont pas 18 ans ouais ouais
mais alors et déjà 30 ans de plus que
moi quand il y avait 48 ans lui avait à
west ham est jeune je suis né
[Musique]
rocio nos gardes au labo de chômage go
ça fait comment ah non ça je dis pas
l'impact et les jardins sa mélopée dont
le prénom n'a pas donné le nom de
famille non non il n'y a pas qu'à man
qui s'appelle martin il s'appelle
comment patrick alors patrick alley bref
pas très gros elle avait référé le
diacre damas hier c'est le seul jeune
que j'aime alors un bouton b juste
ensuite le deuxième match et à quel âge
alors après 4,50 plus tard 4,5 à 22 23
et le rythme était plutôt mal alors 18
ans vous êtes resté convoi de patrick à
main louis 3 3 4 ans soit 80 ou non non
ça s'enchaîne et à machault à ce moment
là ouais t'es show c'était chaud les
marrons chauds début police et d'anciens
métiers
daniel ensuite a eu comme il s'appelait
alors lui jacques jacques oui nous
regardent au bafa gelé il était plus en
plus vieux non mais il vieillissait plus
mieux plus vite que moi vous savez que
vous aviez 22 zones avec une
cinquantaine non antenne moi mais je
peux pas je suis désolé les jeunes ne
peut pas les jeunes peut-être maintenant
ça va servir série mais quand on tourne
maintenant prévoir pour rouler des
pelles va falloir alors prévoir terrado
polydor regardez jean d'ormesson le
charme qu'il a à oui c'est sûr et
ensuite le dernier le dernier est le
dernier week-end à hull 3-1 conséquent
mais c'était il ya trente ans j'étais à
trois quand même et j'avais enchaîné pia
il y avait un mot quand il s'appelait
celui-ci alors celui-là bernard bernard
et on sent lésé voyez les prénoms sort
que lui bien qu'il ne fait pas j'ai pas
qu'il ya pas de bari bernard hill avec l
âge
comme thomas hill vivier c'est un peu
comme moi donc 55 j'ai toujours eu à peu
près 35 ans tondo qui bernard donc vous
aviez 25 ans il nous avait 55 on est
d'accord me fait pas peur parce qu'il
doit être dans un état
[Musique]